- You know, when you talk about
the protests that
happened in 2017
by some far left people at that
time, like as bad as it was
I thought at that time,
I actually quite miss it
because at that time it
was people just yelling
and making a scene and trying
to interrupt the events.
Unfortunately, since then
political violence has
continued to devolve,
not just in Portland,
but actually through
many American cities
and throughout 2020 Portland
and Seattle became the epicenter
of far left American violence.
Where in my home city,
the city you've been to
several times to speak,
there were more than 120 days
of recurring nightly violence.
So, you're in Los Angeles.
I know there was some
rioting that happened
after George Floyd died.
Imagine what you
saw there happening
for four months straight.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and
joining me today's
an American
journalist best known
for covering the Antifa
protests in Portland
and author of the new
already best-selling book
"Unmasked, Inside
Antifa's Radical Plan
"to Destroy Democracy."
Andy Ngo, my friend,
welcome back to
the Rubin report.
- Thank you, Dave.
It's so nice to be
speaking with you again.
Last time we met in studio was
shortly after I was beaten.
- Yeah, you were hurting.
I mean, you were actually
still in quite a bit of pain
and you were medicated
and everything else.
I actually think that's probably
the best place we can
start because I was trying
to chronicle just the amount
of time that I've known you.
And I think I sorta
came aware of you,
we've sort of risen
in the online world
or whatever it is, starting in
around 2015 or so.
In 2016 or 2017 I did an event
at Portland State University
and obviously you're
from Portland.
That's where you do
most of your work
and have uncovered most of
this Antifa stuff there.
I did an event with Christina
Hoff Summers, the feminist,
and Peter Boghossian,
the Philosophy Professor,
and Antifa was there.
It was the first time
that they had ever
protested anything that
I had been part of.
They called me a
homophobe of course,
they called a Christina
misogynist of course,
they called Peter a white
supremacist, of course,
and we did an event
that, you know
had to have a lot of
security and there was a lot
of tension and police had to
escort us and the whole thing.
Anyway, I mention all of
that because I met you right
after the event because
you were covering it
and you were, you know,
you were sort of just
with all due respect,
my friend, you were
like a kid journalist and you
were just kind of figuring
out your thing and now
you've become the center
of what's going on with Antifa.
So first off, my hat off to you.
And now that I've talked
enough to start the show
can you talk just a
little bit about that?
Just sort of where you
started with this whole thing
because now everyone just
thinks you're part of it,
but you were you were
just a scrappy kid
trying to do journalism.
- Yeah, that's right Dave.
Actually I was part
of the student group
that organized the
event that invited you.
So just four years ago
I was just a student journalist,
part of the free
expression group university
who was a fan of yours.
And, you know, it's
been such a privilege
to not just become
better friends
with you over the years,
but then like to rise up
in our careers and a work
because it's really linked.
And I think, you know,
when you talk about the
protest that happened in 2017
by some far left people at that
time, like as bad as it was
I thought at that time,
I actually quite miss it
because at that time it
was people just yelling
and making a scene and
trying to interrupt events.
Unfortunately, since then
political violence has
continued to devolve,
not just in Portland,
but actually
through many American cities
and throughout 2020 Portland
and Seattle became the epicenter
of far left American violence,
where in my home city,
the city you've been to
several times to speak,
there were more than 120 days
of recurring nightly violence.
So, you're in Los Angeles.
I know there was some
rioting that happened
after George Floyd died.
Imagine what you
saw there happening
for four months straight.
That's what happened in Portland
and it's still ongoing now.
It's just become weekly
but it's picked up speed.
This week alone we had,
let's see three riots
in Portland involving Antifa.
- So when you started
seeing this, right,
so as you said, you were
part of a student group
you invite a couple people that
we all considered ourselves
good liberal moderates and
I remember before the event
because there was this
threat of violence
they had to hide us in a room
and we had a police
escort that had to take us
from one room to the event.
By the way, the event
ended up being spectacular.
It's online, we'll link
to it in the bio here.
And it was fun and, you know,
fortunately there
was no violence
but people were angry outside.
So that was sort of the
beginning of all of this.
Then over the last couple years,
it just kept getting bigger
and bigger and
bigger and bigger.
What was it about
it that you saw
that you knew that this
was going to happen?
Because you've been
tracking it the whole time?
- Well I knew it wasn't
just a university
or campus phenomenon.
What we were experienced since
going back to around 2015,
that the ideology that was
justifying these outbursts
of far left rage and
sometimes violence
on campuses would in
that inevitably spill
to the wider cities where
these universities are
and where these students
were returning to.
And that's exactly what happened
very quickly in Portland
and I think the turning
point particular
for its moving, spilling
out, pouring out from academe
into the streets was
the surprise election
winner, Donald Trump.
So that just gave an
excuse for all the accesses
of the far left to go
out and wreck havoc
in the name of anti-fascism,
anti racism, and social justice.
And they were given the
legitimacy they needed
through the mainstream media
and through unfortunately left
wing Democrat politicians.
- Yeah, okay.
So for people that just
see the videos now,
and we've all seen the
videos of what's going
on in Portland and Seattle
and everywhere else.
For people that are
sort of just watching
from the outside that haven't
been to events, you know
I've been protested many times,
you actually helped another
video that I was part
of go viral when I was up in
Canada and Antifa showed up
and they were protesting
that woman in the,
in the walker trying
to cross the street,
calling her a Nazi.
It turned out of course
that her husband was a
veteran of World War II,
literally fought Nazis,
but these are the types
of things that you've
seen over and over.
For people that don't
really pay attention though.
That just see those
little viral videos
and unfortunately you don't
see them on mainstream enough.
What is Antifa?
- See the videos,
I don't think truly
show the threat we're facing.
Some of them do.
But I mean like these
extremists carried
out an insurrection in my
city where night after night
they were going with knives
and guns and explosives
and organizing themselves
into different units
in a marauding gang,
essentially starting fires.
And they eventually
killed somebody.
But to answer your
question, what is Antifa?
It is a movement and
ideology and shadowy networks
of people who call
themselves anti-fascists
but actually espoused
in anarchist,
communist, extremist ideology.
So there's a lot of meaning
in their acts of violence.
I know it can look
kind of meaningless
and without purpose,
but for example,
the attacks on the federal
courthouse in Portland last July
that lasted for weeks
when they try to burn
down that federal
facility, that was because
they viewed the American
criminal justice system
as a system of enslavement
or racism, a remaining relic
of white supremacy.
That's why they were doing that.
That's why they
attack law enforcement
and called for it's abolishment.
That's why they go after
property rights as well.
They view capitalism as
intrinsically linked to racism.
And so like bit by bit,
they've gone after not just
like literal
institutions in America,
but actually I think
more fundamentally
the founding ideals,
the rule of law,
freedom of expression.
I mean Antifa,
probably most known
for their anti-freedom
of expression in that
they believe it has a
not just appropriate
but righteous response to
be preemptively violent
to people who have wrong think
will espouse the wrong views.
- And this was literally what
many of us were talking about
for years saying, you know,
if you label everyone Nazis
and then you say, it's
okay to punch a Nazi,
well you've given yourself
the excuse to basically
not only physically
attack people
but burn down buildings
and everything else.
What do you make of
all of the people?
And we heard this a lot.
I mean, I heard this a
lot from my own people.
Oh, Dave, this is just
a college campus thing.
This won't leak
out into reality.
Clearly they were not correct.
- I wish they were
right, but we've seen,
I mean, the critical ideologies
that have been mainstreamed
in university, these
are then carried
into not just government,
by people who then end
up being advisors
and staff who work
on campaigns and people
who get elected to city
government become leaders
in police departments.
Probably the most
important thing is
that that ideology and takes
root completely in journalism.
So if you look in
the mainstream press
you can see what's
particularly happened at
like America's paper of
record, the New York Times
or the Washington post,
and you just see how
it's a hard left political
monoculture that is
extremely intolerant
and has provided so
much legitimacy to
far-left extremism.
I mean it's these papers who
have published these really
culturally significant
opinion pieces
in news reports as well,
that are sympathetic
or provide a justification
for property destruction,
looting and all that in
the name of social justice.
Online news sites and magazines
are no better.
They also argue for the
need for violent protests.
So they're undoing a lot
of what were norms
in the United States.
And I think this is where
Antifa has had the most success,
not in necessarily their acts
of violence and destruction,
which they have done so much,
created so much
misery from that.
But actually that tenants
of the ideology have found
footing in the mainstream left
and have been giving a
certain legitimacy in society.
And the other thing people
have to realize is that
for those who sympathized with,
when I talked to people
who were supportive
of sympathizing with the
Capitol Hill Siege riot
on the 6th of January, their
response was often, well
for months a month BLM
and Antifa got to riot
in response to their
grievances with violence
and that was cheered on and
nothing happened to them.
So why do we have
to be peaceful?
So this is the danger as well
that it creates,
Antifa's extremism.
It creates reactions
on the right
and the far right that can
lead to a lot of violence.
And we've already
seen a lot in 2020 and
I don't think it's
slowing down this year.
- Yeah, do you sense
that that double standard
where when the lefties, you
know, burn down buildings
and attack private property
and stop cars in the street
and make people, you know,
denounce white supremacism
and the litany of other
things happening, do you think
that the double standard
from the way the media covers
that, to the way they
covered the Capitol obviously
without excusing any of the
violence of the Capitol,
that really is just
completely bursts forth.
Like to me at this point, CNN
is not a place of journalism.
The New York times is not
a place of journalism.
Like, are you willing
to go that far on that?
- Well, what made
me furious in seeing
the condemnations
from journalists,
influential thinkers,
politicians in response
to the riot on the 6th
of January is I
wonder, why they were
at best silent when my city was
under siege, when federal
property in Portland.
- Yeah.
- What those rioters
did on the sixth,
they did that and
worse last year.
Okay, why were they
silent then at best?
And then at worst, some
of them actually were
promoting these crowdfunding
campaigns to get some
of these accused riot
suspects back on the streets.
- Right, so quite
literally, I mean
there were Hollywood celebrities
and quote unquote
journalists putting money in
and crowdfunding to get rioters
that had done violent acts,
illegal acts, to get
them out of jail.
Not that they would have
really been prosecuted
in Portland or Seattle anyway.
- Good point, yes.
- However, I'm fairly
certain if you know anyone
on the right, if Glen
Beck or Ben Shapiro
had done a Go Fund Me to get
some of the January six people,
even if they hadn't been
violent out of jail,
I think it might've been
taken a little differently.
Are you shocked how quickly
the liberals have just folded
on this thing?
You know, my feelings
on this sort of
that this is what
we've seen Antifa do
to the left is sort
of, it's the death end
of liberalism, sort of
and I've watched so many
of my friends just not
be able to understand that.
Are you shocked
that liberals seem
to have no defense
mechanism against this?
- I'm not shocked anymore.
given what's happened
in the past five years.
I mean, when people who,
when liberals systematically
failed to really
defend what the
academy should be about
that was the first sign, right?
If they're not willing to
defend freedom of expression,
the speech in
academic institutions,
I don't think they would
defend it outside of that.
So I'm not shocked, but
I think the reason why
Antifa become really powerful
is because they do have many,
many synthesizers and supporters
on the mainstream left.
People who don't understand
or don't know Antifa's violent,
extremist ideology,
who really think
that these are just merely
people who are anti-fascist,
who are going out to protect
people of color on the street
from neo-Nazis.
I think, and it's
a welfare ignorance
'cause I mean, yes, a lot of
the media has been so reckless
in their coverage of Antifa,
but there's also been
some good coverage.
And, you know, my
work has been printed
in mainstream
publications and all that.
But it's just, I mean, this,
the rule that's been laid
out is essentially you can
do anything and everything
including kill for
the alleged cause
of racial justice
and social justice.
So when you lay that
out as like the context
for all these things to
happen, there's no ability
from the left to really be
able to counter, you know,
and it should be pretty
easy, but you know
Antifa people think that
if you're against them
that means your pro-fa.
If you're against BLM, that
people will accuse you of being
against black Americans,
instead of diving into looking
at what these movements actually
espoused or what they do.
- Have you been able to break
down some of the numbers
on this, like how many of
them actually are there?
How many of them
are taking place?
You know, actually taking
part in the violent attacks
versus I think a
lot of the people
when I see like they're
sort of allies in the media,
like I would look at
somebody like Jake Tapper.
I don't think he's like
a promoter of Antifa.
I think he probably
wishes they didn't exist,
but he's the type of guy
that just won't really
tweet when they're
burning down a city.
But if the right
wing, you know, anyone
on the right does anything,
it's insurrection.
So have you been able to figure
out just like how many
foot soldiers there are
versus how many just
sort of self hostages
in the media who just
don't want to get attacked?
You know just sort of
a general breakdown
of the, amorphous thing.
So exact numbers across
the US would be, I think
impossible to calculate,
just because there's no,
in terms of a lot of
these Antifa organizations
we have actually no idea how
many people are involved.
In my book I look specifically
because I got leaked
public documents internally
from Rose City, Antifa,
which is the Portland Antifa
Organization, the
largest one in the US.
So I can give estimates
for, let's say Portland
because we just, we
have so many data points
of how many recurring
nightly riots,
how many people come.
And for that it
can range anywhere
from as little as 50
people to thousands.
I noticed consistently
though, the number
of people who are actually
dawning their black uniforms
which is a part of the
black block tactics
and those who are committing
the acts of violence.
That numbers really
even at its peak
no more than a couple hundred.
So if there was a political will
and that's the important
word here is political will
to stop this wanting extremism
and violence and destruction
it can be done easily.
However, the mayor really
actually continuously
was giving sort of excuses
for them saying like,
oh I understand that
you're protesting
against racial injustice
and systemic racism.
And just anytime you
buy into that narrative
you're giving legitimacy
to their cause.
So, and unfortunately, Ted
Wheeler, the Mayor of Portland
didn't just, it wasn't
just his rhetoric.
It was actually him
and city council
were implementing
policies such as
restricting local
law enforcement
from actually working with
federal law enforcement.
When these riots were
happening both simultaneously
on federal and city property.
City of Seattle as well
as Portland banned the use
of tear gas,
responding to rioters.
- So what do you think is going
on in the head of a guy like
Portland mayor, Ted Wheeler?
Here's a guy who basically says
to them as they're
burning down his city,
okay, we understand
you're protesting racism.
Then he also handicaps
his police officers.
As you said, he takes away some
of the tactics they can do.
Then Antifa literally shows up
at his apartment complex and
starts attacking the building.
So he has now since moved,
he also gets harassed
now at restaurants,
there's a bunch
of videos on that kind of thing.
And then finally,
a few weeks ago
he said something to
the effect of, you know
we're gonna have to
stop this violence,
but what do you think is
actually going on in his head?
Does he really believe it?
Does he not understand
how law enforcement works?
Is he completely incompetent?
Like what's going on?
And not only him,
you've got the mayor in
Seattle and a bunch of others.
- I think these are people
given the extremely prestigious
education backgrounds
that they recognize
that this is a fringe
violent extremist movement
but because they are first
and foremost politicians
politicians in the
case of Ted Wheeler,
who he ran for reelection
a few months ago,
they are deathly afraid
of being accused of being
against BLM or being against
the cause of anti-fascism.
I think it really
comes to cowardice.
So because of that,
they've given enough space
for these extremists
to work in the city
to the point of where
they're even afraid of them.
I mean, Ted Wheeler in
January of 2021 was assaulted
by some anti-fascist
extremists when he was eating
at a restaurant.
- Right, this is a guy who
literally has basically
let them do whatever they want.
I mean, that's the
irony, of course.
- Yes, that's right.
- Can you talk about how BLM,
how Black Lives Matter the
movement, is connected to this?
'Cause I think people
are very confused
about the associations there.
- BLM is a separate movement
and ideology in terms
of what they are trying
to accomplish in the US,
but they share enough common
goals with Antifa that
as for now, there's a
partnership in my opinion.
And depending on the chapter
it's more explicit than others.
The DC chapter BLM, which
is one of the largest
in the country is probably
the most explicitly
openly allied with Antifa.
But you see this in terms
of Antifa will
volunteer to be security
for these BLM demonstrations.
And that's why they're so able
and easily able to co-op
these demonstrations
and to turn them
quickly into riots,
that's happened in Minneapolis.
You know, all it takes is
the breaching of a business,
a shattering of a window.
And then, you know,
you already have a
whole bunch of agitated
thousands of protesters.
A lot of them will take
the opportunity to loot.
And then once that's done, some
Antifa will then just throw
in a Molotov cocktail and burn
the building to the ground.
But the cross pollination
and ideology is important.
The intersectional ideology
of BLM has cross pollinated
with Antifa's
anarchist communism.
So the traditional Antifa
going back decades now
did not historically
espouse this sort
of hierarchy and Totem poles
of oppressions that you see
in a contemporary
movement like BLM.
However, they share
that in common now.
And for that reason
that just gives Antifa
yet another mantle and
shield to deflect from
because now they're
saying, you know,
they're not just
against fascism,
they're against police
brutality against black people.
You know, the chants
are exactly the same
as the BLM chants and whenever
you see Antifa graffiti
and messages calling
for police to be killed,
you will see Black Lives Matter
and BLM in there as well.
So as I'm now, I consider them
at least in the American
context, linked entities.
- Yeah, is there an
example of a mayor
or a city that has
had the beginnings
of one of these uprisings
that has responded properly?
I can't think of one, but
I suspect maybe somewhere
in Texas or Florida, maybe.
- Yeah so, well,
it's primarily been the red
states who have responded better
in quelling violence
that was getting
out of hand just because
even if it occurred,
even if the riots were occurring
like in a liberal, progressive
city, like Austin let's say,
or Phoenix or
something, they're still
under Republican for
leadership as a governor.
So, you know, there's the use
of the national guard is
on the table and all that,
but even so they've
been pretty well.
I think Wisconsin later on
seeing when there were riots
breaking out in Kenosha
which unfortunately
resulted in deaths,
they were able to shut
that down at least
after several days, rather
than weeks, because,
well they were able
to see what happened
in neighboring Minnesota before
and what was currently ongoing
in Portland and Seattle.
But yeah, it's in terms
of like a blue city
and like a blue city
council and mayor,
I struggle to think of any
that responded very well
immediately and early on.
- Yeah, so, you know, we started
by talking about that first
event in Portland state.
Well, then I saw
you about a year
and a half later
in Portland again,
I saw you when I was on
tour with Jordan Peterson.
And again, we didn't know
each other that well,
but we met right beforehand.
You said, oh, I'd love to sit
down with Jordan
for a few minutes.
And I was able to get you
backstage to chat with Jordan.
I believe that there
is a connection somehow
between the message
that Jordan was putting
out there of clean your
room and take responsibility
for your life and
all of those things
and the counter
to that, the sort
of nihilist destruction
that these people brought.
Because there were especially
in Portland, that was
probably our biggest protest.
Seattle, we had some, but I
think Portland was probably
the biggest one, at least
in the United States.
There was also in
Amsterdam, a pretty big one.
But do you see that, the
message that Jordan was talking
about of personal responsibility
was so counter to them
and that's really why
they hated him so much?
Even though I would
go out there sometimes
with a cap and sunglasses
and talk to them
and they usually didn't know
why they were there protesting
or they would just be out there
and angry and they weren't
sure what was what.
- Yeah, I think it's been
a shame that because of
Dr. Peterson was ill and was out
of the public space for a
few years now, you know,
we really could have benefited,
I think publicly from
his wisdom and voice on
everything that was going on.
I think ultimately for
a lot of the tension.
- Cause they really hated him.
I mean, you know, they really
were were mobbing us online.
The whole thing.
- I think for a lot
of the henchman type
people who are involved
in Antifa street violence,
they're hooligans, the ideology
and message that they
have internalized
is completely antithetical
to the message
of self responsibility
that Dr. Peterson espouses.
So these are people who instead
of cleaning their room or
getting their lives in order
and many of them are
really vulnerable people.
People who are dealing
with mental health issues.
You'll see a lot of them
are recently transgendered.
Many of them are
vagrants and all that.
So instead of being
given a message
of improving their own lives
and the people around them,
they chose to, they
have them polled
until it caught like
ideology that teaches
them that they are to
resolve their grievances
through violence and not
just against other people,
but against society and the
wider world, which is why
the only thing that they are
actually good at is destruction
and creating misery when they
seize territory like they did
in the Capitol Hill Autonomous
Zone in Seattle, Chaz,
all they were able to do
was create an area that led
to attempted rape,
multiple homicide,
shootings, fights, lawlessness.
- Yeah and the mayor
of course let it happen
until they started
showing up at her house.
And then she got rid
of Chaz pretty quickly.
Wait, can you talk about the
transgender element to that?
Because you know, you
often post pictures
of some of the people
that have been arrested
and it's very clear,
a lot of these people
as you said, they're
vagrants, many of them seem
like they're on drugs or
addicts of some kind or another
but the transgender piece
seems sort of interesting
'cause we've all seen
pictures and videos of that.
What's the connection there?
- So disproportionately
the number
of people who have been arrested
and charged at the
riots that happened
in Portland have been
disproportionately
trans in some way.
And so I don't think
that's significant
because unfortunately the
transgenderism has also
become a political ideology
in the United States
and it's been very,
very closely linked
to critical race theory
and critical race theory
I think taken to its
logical conclusion leads
to people believing
that the response
to political disagreements
as violence, for example,
and threats and all that.
So I think there's
a link between A
and B, between why we've
seen so many trans people.
And the other thing
is a lot of them in
my view, treated as sort
of a lot of them as you see
are white and they
don't have a lot
of identity markers
that would make them a
press class of people,
but to suddenly identify
as trans to be non
binary, for example,
then there's suddenly,
you know, queer, whereas
otherwise they would just be
a heterosexual white person.
- Right, otherwise in
essence, they would be
the very thing that they've
come to hate the most
which is a bizarre
existential crisis, I suppose.
So let's flash forward
then to another year.
So I saw you then
in 2018 with Jordan
then I saw you in 2019.
And then there was the sort
of famous incident
when you got attacked.
Can you just recap that moment
for people that don't remember?
- So I was primarily
known regionally
in the Pacific Northwest
since 2017 for a lot
of my coverage of the
Antifa protests and riots.
And that eventually made
me a target, particularly
when I was coupling my video
coverage with reporting
and writing columns that
were getting published
in some of these big papers.
And I was very clear in
describing what I viewed
as a violent extremist movement
that was veiling itself
behind social justice in
carrying out acts of violence
against law enforcement and
private citizens in the city.
And for that, that
made me a target.
And in June of 2019 when
I was covering a protest
turned riot in
downtown Portland,
they saw an opportunity to
in a coordinated fashion
beat me multiple
times on the head.
It led to brain hemorrhage.
When I was trying to walk away
they then threw all
these liquids in my face.
So I couldn't even see.
So that's where the milk
shaking part came from.
So I went on your show, I
think about a month after that.
And you could, if you look close
'cause I started swelling
and a bit of a scab on my eye
but it was the brain injury
that was most serious.
And so I had a whole year
of various medical
treatments to address the
deficiencies that were
caused as a result of that.
And what's tragic about all
of this is that part of
it was caught on video.
It was literally in front
of the justice center,
which is the central
police precinct
and the Sheriff's office.
Not a single person
has been arrested.
So.
- And if I remember correctly
at some point throughout
that you sort of went
to the police officers and
they didn't do anything, right?
- Yeah, it was actually
early in the day because
before people beat me
in the head a couple
of hours before they were
beginning to throw their shakes
at my head and all that.
And I would walk to law
enforcement who were watching
and I'd point out this
individual right here
in that colored backpack
just assaulted me.
I would like to make a report.
And I would like for you
to identify this person
'cause they're
still right there.
And the response to every time
as it was then and afterwards
and before, was always that
they wouldn't get involved.
That they have been given
instructions to stay
on the periphery
and to not step in.
So there's been a breakdown
in not just morale for police
but like the whole
just rule of law period
in some of these places,
Portland, Seattle, it's like
I mean overnight...
- Did you get the sense that
police wanted to help more
than they could,
because when I've been
to some of these things,
I always get the sense
that police wished
they could do more.
Wished that their leaders
would allow them to do more,
in other words.
- Yes, the beat
cops, I, you know
these are the ones who I
have the most sympathy for
but I mean, policing,
you follow the chain
of command and police chiefs
and captains and those high up
are in addition to
being officers, they're
also politicians
in a way because their
career, as you know,
the face of the
police department is
a political position.
And so, you know, that's why
you were seeing police chiefs
and giving the knee during
some of these BLM protests
and being so deferential
to these violent extremists
because that's what's
popular right now.
So I think, yeah, leadership
in these urban areas
have been wanting.
Also a lot of them
wanted, sheriffs as well
wanted to vocally show that
they were anti-Trump as well
and that they were pro the
cause of racial justice.
Therefore, I think that affected
the response from
law enforcement down.
But also there's also an
issue of resources as well.
We've been having
officers resign
in mass and take early
retirement as well.
And as a result of that in
many, many American cities
there's just been a huge upsurge
in homicide shootings, violence.
- Yeah, I mean, we see
this in almost every
progressive city
and now we know also
that the new recruits,
I mean, it's like
why would you want to go into
law enforcement if your mayors
or your governors aren't
gonna have your back?
You know, I know that just
'cause I know you personally
I know that some of the
sort of fame or notoriety
that this has come with is
not what you were looking for.
And when I saw you
that day, you know
a couple of weeks after
you were attacked,
you were obviously having
some mental difficulties
some cognitive stuff
that I'm thrilled to see,
you're better obviously,
but you've sort of
become part of the story
which is a weird thing for
a journalist and Portland
they post about you,
you know, I mean
quite literally things
like kill Andy Ngo.
I mean, there are awful things.
The mobs that come after
you online, like I get a lot
of hate, but your hate
might trump my hate.
Andy, I think it's possible.
Can you talk about that,
about just how personally
that's been for you
and how it sort of sucked
you in to the machine here?
- Yeah, so it's you
know, Antifa's extremism
is not just their
violence on the streets.
A huge part of their
intimidation is done
through online or things that
are borderline not illegal,
such as showing up
at people's homes,
making it known that
they know where you live.
For example,
writing your address
in public places and writing
kill and murder Andy Ngo.
They wanted me to live
under like a constant fear
and it's unfortunately
I thought, they did
succeed in that.
Because at times when
I was just carrying
out regular activities
in life, like going
to the gym or grocery
shopping, one of their members
or sympathizers would recognize
me and post and use some
of these hashtags that would
then be reshared really quickly
with the intended goal to
sort of do a cyber swarm where
through online
information, they show
up in real life
to harass people.
That's actually how they were
able to assault Ted Wheeler.
One of them happened to
see him at a restaurant.
So it's throughout
2020 I'd been,
I was really on borrowed
time in Portland.
They had fully doxed
me, threatened to
kill me many times.
All this is reported to police
and nothing ever happened.
And so.
- Did you ever
try to escalate it
beyond local Portland police?
Like, did you ever talk to
the FBI or anything like that?
- I did report a lot of it
to the FBI and I
never even heard back.
They took an initial report
and nobody followed up with me.
Not even once.
- God, it's just incredible.
So let's talk a
little bit more about
the online component of
this, because I know finally
in the last couple
of weeks it looks
like Twitter did remove a
couple of big Antifa accounts.
We can all debate the
merits of free speech
and whether they were
coordinating violence and all
of that sort of thing, but where
else are they coordinating?
Because I know when they say,
if I tweet something that's
sort of against Antifa
and then I suddenly
get literally thousands
of responses often telling
me to go kill myself
or they're gonna come
get me or whatever
whatever it might be,
that there's obviously
some level of coordination.
There are things happening,
not just on Twitter.
Do you know about those
sorts of networks?
- Yeah, so I write
about that in the book.
A lot of their organizing
actually is done right
in the open through
Twitter and being banned,
it's not really
much of a handicap
to them because these accounts
are all anonymous anyways
and they're plugged
until they're connected
to one another beyond
Twitter, through things such
as signal and telegram so
when a major account is banned
and they open up just
another one immediately,
that is announced
through these channels.
So then they immediately
get new followers.
But in Portland, in particular
Twitter was the platform
where most of the riot
organizing happened.
So you have like all these ad
hoc Antifa groups that popped
up in the summer of
2020 that provided
crowd fundraise for
riot gear, food.
Food was a big thing
and not insignificant
because that helped attract
vagrants who formed a big part
of their part of their
units for rioting.
Money for travel.
They went to other cities.
There was some of them
who went to Kenosha,
some of them who
went to DC, and all
of this was being
done in the open and
on platforms like Go Fund Me,
on Cash App, on
Venmo, and probably
the most successful
campaign in Portland
like Minnesota was
there was a bail fund
that was set up so
that immediately
of the few people who actually
had bales set because their
charges were so serious,
they would immediately get
bailed out, immediately.
And then the charges
would be dropped anyways.
So they would get the money back
and they would reinvest that
in other things such
as giving grants
to other Antifa chapters.
So this is what I
mean, this issue
of allowing it to go on so
long is that these systems
and networks will last
long beyond summer of 2020.
And a lot of that
unfortunately is also
out of the reach
of law enforcement
such as the encrypted
communications that happen
on Signal or Telegram.
- Right and we know
that a whole bunch of
Hollywood celebrities were
promoting those Go Fund
Mes to get these guys out
and am I mistaken?
But didn't Kamala
Harris actually promote
one at one time?
- She did, I write
about that in the book.
So she tweeted out a link
to her millions of followers
for the Minnesota Freedom Fund
which was the group
that paid the bail
for accused rioters
in Minnesota.
But it wasn't just rioters
that were being bailed out.
This organization was
also paying the bail for
accused murderers,
accused rapists.
- I mean just staggering stuff.
What about the relationship
though with big tech?
Because obviously after the
Capitol Hill riots on the sixth
we know what
happened with Parler.
Their servers were
taken out by Amazon.
We know Trump was banned
by basically everybody.
As I said before, a
couple Antifa accounts
have been taken out
but they really do
play footsie with these things.
And as you just said,
Twitter is probably
the main culprit here.
- Yeah, so they've taken
down a few Antifa accounts
but these are just drops
in the bucket and the Rose
City Antifa it's still on
the East Liberation Front,
it's still on Twitter.
And these are groups
that were instrumental
in years of violence
in Portland.
But the thing with
big tech is, I mean
their bias is no secret.
I think it's just, it's the
same thing with journalism.
Like the staff, the
people who are making
up the workforce are
these large corporations.
They're largely
influential to, excuse me,
sympathetic to the cause
of what they believe these
extremists are doing.
- Right, which then
causes them to allow a lot
of this stuff to just slide
while on the other side,
they certainly wouldn't
be as accommodating.
What do you think is sort
of coming with all of this?
Because, you know,
there were a lot
of people as 2020 ended,
there was a real feeling
at least in the mainstream
media, like, oh, all right
we got rid of Trump.
You know, now BLM can calm
down, Antifa can calm down.
Things will get better.
Clearly after the sixth and
now everything that we've seen
in our 20 some odd
days of January 2021,
like it doesn't seem like
things are gonna calm down.
What do you think?
- Well, it didn't calm
down starting in November.
In November in Portland in
response to Biden winning,
the people who
took to the streets
weren't Trump
supporters in Portland,
they were Antifa and
they marched around.
They just severely damaged
a church in their riot.
The national guard was finally
activated for the first time
that night, too little
too late, in my view.
I think what's going forward is
that everything is like the
path has already been paved.
The mainstreaming of the nut
tenants of their ideology.
The allies that they've gained
in important institutions
have been made.
And of course then the refined
and perfected blueprints
for insurrection has also
had, it had months and months
of opportunity to improve
and establish itself.
So this whole, I mean the
whole pretense that gave
Antifa their meteoric rise in
2016 was in response to Trump
which they said was the
rise of American fascism.
I mean, that was
rubbish at the time.
It was a lie.
Unfortunately they were, that
argument was given legitimacy
through the mainstream press.
But with Trump out of the
way, it's immaterial anyways
because their opposition
really is not to Trump,
it's to the United States and
what its standing ideals are.
So these agitations to
attack the US will continue.
And they've lashed on currently
to attacking law enforcement
because that's gonna
be around regardless
of what administration
would be in power.
- Yeah, do you think Biden
will do anything with this?
I mean, again, this is
where my frustration
with the last few
liberals is just,
it's totally out in the open.
I kept warning everybody
like this, isn't gonna stop.
This isn't gonna stop
and now you have a guy
playing footsie with
all of those ideologies
who's putting critical race
theory back into the system.
So let's not pretend
that he's gonna do anything
to stop any of this stuff.
- Biden, to his credit has
been very clear when asked
about political violence,
he denounces it,
but I mean, it's not.
- But didn't he say
Antifa's just an idea?
Remember that?
It's just an idea.
- He did, but let me
qualify my praise of him.
I don't think it's him
who's really an executive.
You can see it.
It's the DNC.
- [Dave] Yeah.
- So, you know, when it,
when there was the
inauguration day riots
in Washington State
and Oregon by Antifa,
Jen Psaki, the press
secretary was asked
about that and she didn't
really have a response.
She didn't condemn it either.
I think like that lack
of, I guess, moral clarity
so far by the administration
is it's like, well, you know
like what these rioters
were doing were very similar
to what the rioters did
on the 6th of January
but why do you not
treat it as important?
Why does administration
not view it as important?
And so, I mean like
Antifa's just gonna
be able to kind of
go under the radar
of the mainstream press
and the administration
in DC as they're
carrying out acts
of carnage continually in
other major American cities
on the other part
of the country.
- Yeah Andy, before we wrap here
we should talk a little
bit about what happened
at that bookstore in Portland
because your book, which
comes out this week, and again
the link to it is right below,
you are selling I don't even
know if you have the numbers.
You don't have to share
them with me right now,
but we know internally
through the publishing houses,
you're doing all
right at the moment.
The book is taking
off in many ways
in large part to
these crazy protests.
By the way, something
very similar
happened to me back in April
where they all coordinated
to ruin all my book reviews
but then that causes a backlash
and then people actually
read the book and they go,
oh, this isn't that dangerous.
But in Portland, they were
protesting a bookstore.
There was all sorts of
stuff happening over there.
Can you just tell
people that story?
'Cause it's just like a
perfect little microcosm
of everything that's
going on here.
- Yeah in January, this year
in response to the
book coming out soon,
the Antifa in Portland
chose to surround
and protest for six days,
Portland's largest
bookstore, Pals Books,
which is quite an important
institution in the city.
And they weren't
just, it's not just
about them protesting
the book who, I mean,
who cares that they
don't like the idea of it
even though they
haven't read it.
They were calling
for it to be banned.
and the bookstore
partially gave into that.
They said that, they
announced preemptively
that the book would not be
sold on any of its shelves,
but Antifa weren't
happy with that
because they wanted it removed
from the online catalog as well.
I mean, that was not
surprising to see.
It's disheartening,
it's disturbing to see
obviously for modern
people calling
for books to be banned, even
when they haven't read them.
But I think, I guess the
silver lining that is
their protests help bring a lot
of attention to this
book that was coming out.
And so a lot of people
weren't even aware that
"Unmatched" was coming out.
So I'm really thankful
to people who have
pre-ordered it so far.
And you know, really thankful
that you allow me to come
on your show again and talk
about why this is so important
and what this book is about.
- Yeah, well Andy, I just
want to say personally
I'm thrilled for your success.
I'm beyond thrilled that
you're healthy again
and that we have people
like you out there because
I know you from years ago
and you just wanted
to do journalism where
in a time when everyone does
quote unquote journalism.
So I'm glad you're doing well.
I know you're dealing with a lot
of craziness in the midst
of this whole thing.
And I'm, just seeing your
successes is an example
that if you stand up
for what you believe in
that good things can happen.
So listen people
don't burn this book.
"Unmasked, Inside
Antifa's Radical Plan
"to Destroy Democracy."
We've got the link to it down
below, and I look forward
to seeing you again, my friend.
- Thank you.
- If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about the media
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our media playlist.
And if you want to
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out the full episode playlist.
They're both right over here
and to get notified
of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.